in most of the world horse racing is a
fast-paced head spinning event but he
runs appends northernmost island
Hokkaido the races move on yay is a form
of horse racing found only in Hokkaido
in which draft horses pull heavy sleds
down a 200 meter dirt track the sleds
can range from 900 to 2,000 pounds so
Bonnier horses are often twice as big as
their speedy counterparts
Kazuki Kikuchi has been a bond yet
jockey for the past nine years but the
history of this race goes back much
further by a caveat
Meiji niju named katakana chozo toast a
charitable event even attaching a mono
Iranian VD they saw sohcahtoa
Kakashi mono comatose state Mikasa
Hatake on our stage data array in your
day sorry not me no do not stop the
popularity of the races grew and
starting in the 1950s there were four
cities hosting races across Hokkaido
however in recent years interest has
waned and today the races are only held
at this racetrack but that didn't stop
Kikuchi
Management Authority Network and we must
stay okay thank you sir
pulling one-ton sleds is no easy task
but these draft horses race only every
two weeks and in between they're well
taken care bye-bye
Kaiba normal eating ji-yong so cool
Tabitha co-insurance
yes my mono/stereo state mochi revisited
okay an Omani Kanaka qualitative even
the museum's aki-nee Sakura do you go
talk to say Kokua arrange a schedule
Chikara given a hockey deck irani
Torrico Simmons and for first-time
spectators seeing bunny horses can be a
bit of a shock jock Thomas I saw one
Oxana older - Jason Tony it's cockamamie
forever
great guy okay
there have been signs that bunny racing
may be regaining popularity either way
kikuchi is happy to be part of this
tradition I gave up Muhammadans bananas
but it's very nice bottle of there to
hold it during putting our hands